you now know what a transformation is so
let's introduce a more of a special kind
of transformation called a linear linear
transformation transformation it only
makes sense that we have something
called a linear transformation because
we're studying linear algebra we already
had linear combination so we might as
well have a linear transformation and a
linear transformation by definition is a
transformation which we know is just a
function we could say it's from the set
RM let me say it from RN to RM and it
might be obvious in the next video why
I'm being a little bit particular about
that although they are just arbitrary
letters where the following two things
have to be true so if some if something
is a linear transformation something is
a linear transformation if and only if
the following thing is true let's say
that we have two vectors say vector a
and let's say vector B are both members
of RN so they're both in our domain so
that this is a linear transformation if
and only if if I take the transformation
of the sum of our two vectors if I take
if I add them up first that's equivalent
to taking the transformation of each of
the vectors taking the transformation of
each of the vectors and then summing
them that's my first condition for for
this to be a linear transformation and
then the second one is is that if I take
the transformation of any scaled up
version of a vector so let me just
multiply vector a times some scalar some
real number see if this is a linear
transformation then this should be equal
to C times the transformation of a that
seems pretty straightforward let's see
if we can apply these rules to figure
out if some actual transformations are
linear or not so let me define a
transformation let's say that I have the
transformation T part of my definition
I'm going to tell you it's it maps from
R to 2 let's do something let's just say
it maps from R to
- our - and my deaf and it Maps so if
you give it a 2-tuple right it's domain
is 2-tuple so you give it an X 1 and
then X 2 let's say it Maps 2 so this
will be equal to or it's associated with
let me it's associated with let me just
say let's say X 1 plus X 2 and then
let's just say it's 3 times X 1 is the
second tuple we could have written this
more in vector form this is kind of our
tuple form we could have written it and
it's good to see all the different
notations that you might encounter you
could write it a transformation of some
vector X where the vector looks like
this X 1 X 2 let me put a bracket there
it equals it equals some new vector X 1
plus X 2 and then the second component
of the new vector would be 3 X 1 that's
a completely legitimate way to express
our transformation and the third way
which I never see but to me it kind of
captures the essence of what a
transformation is it's just a mapping or
it's just a function we could say that
the transformation is a mapping from any
vector in r2 that looks like this X 1 X
2 2 and I'll do this notation to a
vector that looks like this X 1 plus X 2
and then 3 X 1 all of these statements
are equivalent but our whole point of
writing this is to figure out whether T
is linearly independent so I want to
sorry not linearly independent whether
it's a linear transformation I was so
obsessed with linear independence for so
many videos it's hard to get it out of
my brain in this one whether it's a
linear transformation so let's test our
two conditions I have them up here so
let's take T of let's say I have two
vectors a and B they're members of r2 so
let me write it a is equal to a 1 know a
1 a 2 and B is equal to B 1
be - sorry that's not a vector I have to
make sure that those are scalars these
are the components of a vector and B -
so what is a 1 + B I'm sorry what is a
vector A plus vector B brains
malfunctioning all right well you just
add up their components this is the
definition of vector addition so it's a
1 plus B 1 out of the first components
and the second components is just the
sum of each of the vector second
components a2 + b2 nothing new here but
what is the transformation of this
vector so the transformation the
transformation of vector A plus vector B
we could write it like this that would
be the same thing as the transformation
of this vector which is just a 1 plus B
1 + a2 + b2 which we know it equals a
vector it equals this vector where what
we do is for the first component here we
add up the two components on this side
so the first component here is going to
be these two guys added up so it's a 1
plus a 2 plus B 1 plus B 2 and then the
second component by our transformation
or our function definition is just 3
times the first component in the NR in
our domain I guess we could say it so
it's 3 times the first one so that's
going to be 3 times this first guy so
it's 3 a 1 plus 3 B 1 fair enough now
what is the transformation individually
of a and B so the transformation of a is
equal to the transformation of a let me
write it this way it's equal to the
transformation of a 1 a 2 in brackets
that's our another way of writing vector
a and what is that equal to that's our
definition of our transformation right
up here so this is going to be equal to
the vector a 1 plus a 2 and then 3 times
a 1 just come straight out of definition
I essentially just replaced an X with a
z'
by the same I guess argument by the same
argument what is the transformation of
our vector B well else this is going to
be the same thing with the a is replaced
by the B so it's the transformation of
our vector B is going to be B you know B
is just B 1 B 2 B 1 B 2 so it's going to
be B 1 plus B 2 and then the second
component and the transformation will be
3 times B 1 now what is what is the
transformation of vector a plus the
transformation of vector B what's this
vector plus that vector and what is that
equal to well this is just pure vector
addition so we just add up their
components so it's a 1 plus a 2 plus B 1
plus B 2 that's just that component plus
that component the second component is 3
a 1 we're going to add it to that second
component so it's 3 a 1 plus 3 B 1 now
we just showed you that if I take the
transformation separately of each of the
vectors and then add them up I get the
exact same thing as if I took the
vectors and added them up first and then
took the transformation so we've met our
first criteria that the transformation
of the sum of the vectors is the same
thing as the psalm of the
transformations now let's see if this
works with the width with a random
scalar so we know what the
transformation of a looks like what is
the transformation but what does C a
look like first of all I guess that's a
good place to start
C times our vector a is going to be
equal to C times a 1 and then C times a
2 that's our definition of scalar
multiplication times a vector so what's
our transformation let me go to a new
color
what is our let me do a color I haven't
used in a long time white what is our
transformation of see a going to be well
that's the same thing as our
transformation of ca1 ca2 which is equal
to a new vector we're the first term
let's go to our definition is you sum
the first you sum the first and second
components and the second term is 3
times the fur
component so our first term you sub them
so it's going to be C a1 plus C a2 and
then our second term is 3 times our
first term so it's 3 C a1 now what is
this equal to this is the same thing we
can kind of you could view it as
factoring out the C this is the same
thing as C times the vector a1 plus a2
and then the second component is 3 a1
but this thing right here we already saw
this is the same thing as the
transformation of a transformation of a
so just like that you see that the
transformation of C times our vector a
for any vector a and r2 this is anything
in r2 can be represented this way it's
the same thing as C times the
transformation of a so we've met our
second condition that it doesn't that
when you when you well I just stated it
so I don't have to restate it so we meet
both conditions we meet both conditions
which tells us that this is a linear
transformation and you might be thinking
ok Sal fair enough that was you know how
do I know that all transformations
aren't linear transformation show me
something that that won't work and here
I'll do a very simple example let me
define my transformation and just to
make it oh let me let me do one let me
make it let me define a transformation
I'll do it from r2 to r2 just for just
to kind of compare the two I could have
done it from R to R if I wanted a
simpler example but I'm going to define
my transformation let's say my
transformation of the vector x1 x2 let's
say it is equal to let me just say x1
the squared and then 0 just like that
let me see if this is a linear
transformation so the first question is
if if let's let's take what's my
transformation of a vector a so my
transformation of a vector a where a is
just the same a that I did before it
would look like this it would look like
a 1 squared and then
zero now what would be my transformation
would be my transformation if I took C
times a C times a well this is the same
thing as C times a 1 and C times a 2 and
by our transformation definition if I
take I sorry the transformation of C
times of this thing right here because
I'm doing the transformation on both
sides and by our transformation
definition this will be just be equal to
a new vector that would be in our
codomain where we the first term is just
the first term of our input squared so
it's C a1 squared C a1 squared and the
second term is 0 and what is this equal
to let me switch colors this is equal to
C squared a1 squared and this is equal
to 0 now let's let's see if we can
factor out if we well if we can assume
that C does not equal 0 this would be
equal to what this would be actually it
doesn't even matter we don't even have
to make that assumption
so let's this is the same thing this is
equal to C squared times the vector a 1
squared 0 which is equal to what this is
equal this expression right here is the
transformation of a so this is equal to
C squared times the transformation of a
let me do it in the same color times the
transformation of a so what I've just
showed you is if I take the
transformation of a vector being
multiplied by a scalar quantity first
that that's equal to for this T for this
for this transformation that I've
defined right here that's equal to C
squared times the transformation of a
and clearly this this this statement
right here for this choice of
transformation conflicts conflicts with
this requirement for a linear
transformation have a see here I should
see a C here but in our case I have a C
here and I have a C squared here so
clearly this negates that statement so
we're definitely not dealing so this is
this is not
a linear transformation and just to get
a gut feel if you're just looking at
something whether it's going to be a
linear transformation or not if the
transformation just involves linear
combinations of the different components
of the inputs you're probably dealing
with the linear transformation if
something if you start seeing things
where the components start getting
multiplied by each other or you start
seeing squares or exponents you're
probably not dealing with the linear
transformation and then there are some
functions that might be in a bit of a
gray area but it tends to be just linear
combinations are going to deal lead to a
linear transformation but hopefully that
gives you a good sense of things and
this leads up to what I think is one of
the neatest outcomes in the next video